[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 europe une
émission enregistrée au parlement
européen à bruxelles notre invité pour
cette émission et stéphanie von euw vice
présidente du conseil régional d'île de
france en charge des affaires
européennes
ensemble nous évoquerons son rôle est le
lien qui peut exister entre la région
ile de france et le continent européen
nous vous présenterons aussi durant
cette émission comme d'habitude un père
fondateur de l'union européenne il sera
question également de transport en
commun
nous verrons si nos voisins sont mieux
lotis en termes de prix ou de qualité à
des transports stéphanie bonnes oeuvres
bonsoir moi ça vous est donc vice
présidente du conseil régional d'île de
france en charge des affaires
européennes depuis les élections de 2015
les élections régionales
vous êtes également secrétaire national
des républicains adjointe au maire à
pontoise dans le val d'oise et donc vous
est présente à tous les échelons
territoriale de la politique communale
régionale nationale et même européenne
avec votre titre à la région c'est un
avantage pour vous de pouvoir agir à
tous les échelons alors ça complique un
peu la tâche est de se retrouver
j'ai un pas que ça allait compliquer
parce que évidemment ça ça les agendas
sont un peu chargé mais en revanche ça
simplifie les choses en termes de
conduite de projets parce que la
difficulté qu'on a notamment en france
et ce fameux millefeuille territorial et
c'est bien de pouvoir de savoir comment
ça fonctionne à chaque échelon d'avoir
des relais à chaque échelon et jusqu'à
présent ce qui manquait beaucoup y
compris à l'échelon de la région ile de
france qui pourtant une grosse région
c'était cet ancrage européen cette
capacité à décoder à déchiffrer et puis
à actionner les leviers européen et
c'est la raison pour laquelle valérie
pécresse a souhaité qu' une
vice-présidence donc en l'occurrence
contrat soit soit dévoilé cette mission
alors je suppose qu'avec votre titre à
la région ile-de-france l'histoire de
l'europe est un sujet qui vous intéresse
et notamment les pères fondateurs chaque
mois atv 78,2 vous fait découvrir celles
et ceux qui ont participé à la
construction européenne ce mois-ci
alcide
gasperi d'abord autrichien plus italien
alcide de gasperi a une particularité
c'est un thème des frontières il fut
président du conseil italien ministre
des affaires étrangères il a joué aussi
un rôle de médiateur entre la france et
l'allemagne après la seconde guerre
mondiale les détails de son parcours
avec philippe le guen directeur de
l'association jean monnet basée dans les
yvelines
[Musique]
altit et de gasperi et est un
intéressant parce que c'est un homme des
frontières aussi puisque quand il est né
dans cette partie du conte appelle le
trentin le nord de l'italie un le sud de
l'autriche
cette partie là était une possession de
l'autriche hongrie
donc il a été d'abord autrichien il a
été un homme politique autrichien
députés à à vienne au parlement de
vienne
et puis ensuite après la première guerre
mondiale
l'autriche
dans les dommages de guerre a perdu ses
possessions en italie du nord qui a été
rattaché à l'italie donc il est ensuite
devenu un député est très tôt il s'est
vraiment dresser contre le fascisme de
mussolini
après la guerre il a pu donc à travers
le parti catholique italien la db créer
ce qu'on a appelé la démocratie
chrétienne en italie et ça l'a amené
jusqu'à être président du conseil
italien donc l'équivalent pour nous du
chef de l'état en italie et à ce moment
là ça a coïncidé avec le projet de
première communauté du charbon et de
l'acier de robert schuman
soutenu par adenauer ce il a tout de
suite adhéré à ce projet là en voulant
en encre et l'italie dans dans cet
espace européen
d'une part parce que l'italie évidemment
la vérité du mauvais côté pendant la
guerre pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale mais aussi parce qu'il a vu un
ça comme une opportunité aussi pour
moderniser le pays et surtout relancer
son économie
il a su aussi expliqué que ce projet là
était bénéfique au pays est en effet le
pays était meurtri le pays était divisé
politiquement c'est qu'en italie le
l'union italienne c'est quelque chose
quand même d'assez récent donc
de gasperi est généralement considéré
comme quelqu'un de rassembleur et qui a
su mettre le pays après la guerre sortir
le pays de l'ornière et il est
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui incontestablement
reconnu que ce soit à gauche ou à droite
de l'échiquier politique italien
l'avenir ne se construit pas grâce à la
force mais grâce à la patiente
application de la méthode démocratique à
l'esprit constructif des accords et au
respect de la liberté
[Musique]
stéphanie von euw vous êtes vous aussi
si je puis dire un petit peu historique
à la région ile de france puisque vous
en êtes membre depuis delà du conseil
régional depuis 2004 et donc depuis deux
ans et vice présidente en charge des
affaires européennes
ça montre du coup que la région vous le
disiez s'intéressent aux sujets
européens mais pourquoi alors
concrètement qu'est-ce qui est quel est
l'intérêt pour la région ile de france
d'avoir une vice présidente en charge
des affaires européennes c'est de
récupérer des fonds ici à bruxelles
principalement alors pas que oui bien
sûr mais pas que pour être une ré jour
extraordinairement performante
il fait en capacité de travailler à
plusieurs
il faut être en capacité d'être entendu
à bruxelles auprès de la commission de
ou de l'union européenne
d'abord pour faire entendre les
difficultés que nous ressentons sur
notre territoire pour éventuellement
être aidées pour faire en sorte que des
décisions des réglementations des
législations ne soit pas prise alors
qu'elles ne sont pas conformes à nos
besoins ou aux intérêts des acteurs des
acteurs franciliens ça c'est le premier
sujet le deuxième sujet c'est
d'entretenir et de valoriser cette
culture européenne parce qu'on est
profondément européen et on souhaite que
cette culture européenne
infuser diffuse encore plus largement
sur le territoire et pas simplement dans
ce que j'appelle le le club des
européens qui sont des convaincus moi je
veux vraiment qu'on ait une dimension
clairement affichée en matière
européenne
et puis le troisième élément vous l'avez
dit vous-même c'est quand même un peu
les sous son ventre sonnants et
trébuchants donc c'est évidemment sinon
le nerf de la guerre en tout cas en tout
cas important
et là dessus nous avons les fonds
européens qui sont gérés en direct par
la région et on va probablement dire un
mot qui nous sont confiés par la
commission européenne en direct mais il
ya également d'autres programmes de
financement ou là clairement on souhaite
positionner la région comme une aide
comme une plateforme qui permet de
solliciter des financements qu'une
association de collectivités ou même une
entreprise ne pourrait pas solliciter
tout seul alors juste une réaction vous
parliez de politique européenne qui
doivent pas aller on va dire contre les
contre les franciliens ce que ça veut
dire que la région ile de france a les
moyens de peser sur la politique de
l'union européenne
concrètement tout tout seul dans
mais en revanche en organisant des
coopérations avec d'autres régions qui
ressemble à la région ile de france je
pense par exemple je je voyais ce matin
nos homologues de la région de milan
nous avons donc un pack spécial
on est en train de voilà alors avec la
catalogne s'est déjà réalisée on est en
train de faire la même chose avec la
région de milan on est je reçois ennour
valérie pécresse reçoit prochainement
mon homologue de la bavière pour
précisément peser à plusieurs sur un
certain nombre de sujets qui nous sont
communs à savoir s'agissant de la
politique d'aménagement du territoire
on est considéré depuis bruxelles ces
trois régions là comme des régions
riches et que donc on n'aurait pas
besoin d'argent européen en la matière
et nous pensons que c'est une grave
erreur pour une raison simple c'est
qu'il ya des disparités territoriales
des très fortes en soit exactement et
que c'est pas parce que la région
ile-de-france en général est plutôt des
régions riches qu'il n'y a pas des
poches de difficultés particulières cc
message là qu'il faut comporte ensemble
pour que la future politique nous soit
nous soient adaptés et vous disposez
aussi d'une permanence ici qu'on appelle
à bruxelles
ile de france europe ça permet de
rencontrer plus facilement les décideurs
lewis est le principe de base loin des
yeux loin du coeur
donc même si paris n'est qu'à une heure
vingt de thalys de bruxelles
malgré tout on n'y est pas donc c'est
des modes de fonctionnement des cultures
des habitudes de travail qu'il faut
qu'on entretienne c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a un bureau qui est très
performant pas très nombreux ainsi
personne mais qui est performant
répartis par thématique et dont l'objet
est de faire le relais
bien sûr de la région entend conseil
régional mais pas seulement c'est tous
les acteurs franciliens peuvent
s'adresser à notre bureau à bruxelles
pour les définitions exactement ça peut
être des collectivités des élus
les administrations des associations des
entreprises pme journalistes aussi les
journalistes absolument donc on est là
pour faire le pour faire le relais
ça veut pas dire que parce que on
intervient ça marche à tous les coups
mais en tout cas on peut parvenir à
ouvrir davantage de portes et à
construire peut-être un projet plus en
plus d'envergure qu'est ce qu'il en
allait tout ça alors vous le disiez
bruxelles consacré un budget important
pour aider les régions à réduire les
inégalités et les problèmes structurels
dans de nombreux domaines social
environnemental emploi transport c'est
ce qu'on appelle du coup les fameux
fonds européens en tout entre 2014 et
2020 pour toutes les régions de l'europe
ses 960 milliards d'euros qui sont
consacrés combien pour la région ile de
france vous disiez régions riches
est ce que dit le droit d'autre part les
yoris mais alors tout ça forcément on
rentre un peu dans la bataille dans la
bataille de chiffres nous on estime que
c'est pas beaucoup mais on pourra
estimer que c'est beaucoup en fait sur
six ans nous avons une enveloppe de 540
millions d'euros
540 millions d'euros c'est beaucoup et
peu à la fois parce que c'est quand même
une région de douze 12 millions
d'habitants d'autres régions françaises
par exemple un peu plus d'un milliard
d'euros voire deux donc on voit un peu
le delta mais charge à nous au delà de
cette enveloppe
charge à nous justement d'être qu'elle
soit bien dépenser intelligemment
dépenser de la manière la plus
pragmatique et simple possible
et quand je dis ça ça peut paraître
évident sauf que un des sujets avec les
financements européens c'est que c'est
complexe et donc nous notre boulot à la
région les principaux intéressés
complexe pour les acteurs pour ceux qui
en bénéficient j'ai souvent je dis
souvent que le problème des financements
européens c'est quand on veut s'attaquer
un financement européen ou en
bénéficient on a l'impression d'aller
gravir l'everest avec des tongs et nous
rendait en est là pour faire en sorte de
simplifier un maximum les choses alors
540 millions d'euros pour la région de
france m'a alors destiné à qui et pour
quoi faire donc alarmant qui peut avoir
accès à ces à ses 540 millions d'euros
beaucoup de gens ce sont ces taxis
arrivent les noix par lui absolument
peut y avoir peut y avoir accès c'est le
tissu associatif
ce sont les collectivités territoriales
quelle que soit leur taille
c'est également tout le tissu de tpe pme
d'artisans qui bocquillon qui ont accès
donc ça c'est pour les cibles après
c'est là où ça devient un tout petit peu
plus compliqué c'est que vous l'avez
rappelé toutes les thématiques ne sont
pas éligibles aux fonds européens et on
a on va dire une dizaine dax a cédé
programmes différents leaders effet ce
tout ça c'est très technique très ceal
ces techniques ont repris tard rentrée
dedans on a des services qui sépare le
fond c'est pour qu'elles quel domaine du
coup concrètement alors donc il ya vous
je vous dis une dizaine dax les deux
axes principaux un conte retrouves assez
régulièrement c'est tout ce qui tourne
autour de l'âtre autre transition
énergétique toute la réhabilitation
énergétique des bâtiments
tout ce qu'ils retournent autour de
l'innovation de la recherche et du
développement
également la butte par exemple les
inégalités sociales petite mairie de
2500 habitants qui souhaitent refaire la
rénovation énergétique de ces écoles ou
de ses bâtiments publics potentiellement
il est éligible
j'allais vous demander justement un
exemple concret de projets qui ont été
financés par exemple dans les yvelines
moi j'ai rien une à park
d'éco-construction à carrières sous
poissy avec une participation des fonds
européens 1 million 400 mille euros soit
50 % du montant c'est à dire que
l'europe à financer 50% vers ce parc des
concurrents se disant absolument
et donc on voit qu'il ya des des sommes
importantes qui peuvent êtres qui
peuvent être apportées après c'est vrai
que c'est une instruction des dossiers
qui sont relativement lourds a à monter
mais parce qu'on veut que ce soit
efficace et qu'on veut que l'argent
européen arrive dans les territoires et
qu'on puisse démontrer à travers eux que
l'europe elle est concrète elle est
proche des gens et les finances des
choses très précises et ça aussi cette
méfiance exact n'a peut-être
l'impression que l'europe est loin des
territoires mais ces rencontres s'est
pas adapté et donc nous on est là on a
mis une équipe totalement en place pour
faciliter les choses c'est à dire que
vous êtes une association de
collectivités une entreprise qui
souhaitaient monter un projet européen
eh bien on vous met un interlocuteur à
votre disposition et vous aider à monter
le dossier avec qui va vous suivre du
début jusqu'à la fin
le début peut s'arrêter très vite c'est
à dire qu'on vous dira tout de suite si
vous êtes dans les clous pas ça sert à
rien d'essayer de faire irruption jeudi
sachs un toutou il ya une dizaine il ya
une dizaine dax après je vais pas
rentrer dans les détails mais mais c'est
comme avec les conduire à se renseigner
sur internet et sur tout et sur internet
vous avez un référent qui vous prend par
la main il y avait même des ateliers
d'écriture qu'on organise pour aider les
différents acteurs à monter leur dossier
et nous avons même une équipe de
développeurs se sont que des femmes mais
répartis sur les différentes thématiques
qui ont vocation à aller dans les
départements dans à la rencontre des uns
et des autres même sur sur demande pour
aller expliquer ce qui existe le champ
du possible champs de l'impossible mais
en tout cas faciliter cet accès et vous
même la région vous pouvez pousser des
dossiers proposés ou alors ce sont que
des personnes qui peuvent venir vous
voir et des associations des
collectivités qui doivent se proposait
les deux mon capitaine
très concrètement comment ça fonctionne
c'est à dire que c'est la région qui
lancent des appels à projets qui lancent
des appels à projets avec un cahier des
charges en disant voilà ce mois ci c'est
telle thématique qui est lancé on lance
un appel à projets et charge ensuite à
aux personnes intéressées donc je vous
dis associations collectivités ou
entreprises qui sont intéressés de
répondre à l'appel à projet et ensuite
nous on revient vers elle pour instruire
le dossier 540 millions d'euros
il ya autant d'habitants d'ailleurs dans
l'union européenne
sur 2014 2020 combien de crédit utilisée
aujourd'hui actuellement combien de
alors aujourd'hui on est à peu près 40 %
de la programmation de ces de ces
enveloppes
il ya eu un effort de rattrapage très
important puisque quand on est arrivé en
décembre 2015 on était seulement à 0,35
pour cent de programmation donc ce qui
était un petit peu inquiétant parce que
il ya un système avec les fonds
européens qui est que au bout de deux ou
trois ans si vous n'avez pas consommer
un pourcentage minimum de votre
enveloppe et bien il ya ce qu'on appelle
le dégagement d'office donc c'est y
sommes eh bien vous les retirera donc on
va pas dire que certes on est une région
riche mais on a besoin d'argent comme
tout le monde et les projets ont besoin
d'être financés et donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle on a souhaité vraiment ce
se donner les moyens de faciliter et
d'accélérer un maximum les choses alors
c'est loin mais 2021 ce sera la nouvelle
période on va dire pour avoir ces fonds
là où vous pouvez en avoir plus comment
comment sont calculés non on fait tout
pour on fait tout pour
j'ai différents rendez vous notamment
quand je vais à bruxelles justement pour
essayer de peser sur la future politique
de cohésion qui est celle dont qui
traitent des fonds structurels européens
pour leur dire que des régions comme la
région ile-de-france ont besoin d'abord
parce qu'il n'est pas exclu que si on
fait dans le ciel d'abord à bruxelles
c'est de se dire que la région ile de
france n'a pas besoin des flux bas ils
ont tendance à dire que c'est une
politique d'aménagement du territoire
qui est plutôt faite pour les régions
qui sont un peu décrochés ou qui ont
besoin d'un effort particulier pour
faire un rattrapage en termes
d'investissement ou de fonctionnement et
que la région ile de france est une
région développer donc on aurait
éventuellement besoin de moins moins que
d'autres
donc nous on dit que on est comme les
autres on a des gros gros besoin compte
tenu
nos poches territoriales et puis on est
force de proposition parce que c'est pas
une seule chose de dire on veut garder
les sous c'est aussi de dire d'être
apporteur de solutions en termes de
simplification des choses dont on veut
je viens de proposer à une proposition
de labellisation des régions qui aura
fait la démonstration qu'elles savent
bien les gérer donc y aurait des
contrôles allégée par exemple donc on
est vraiment en train d'amorcer un
processus de réflexion et d'apports de
solutions pour le poste 2020 et faire en
sorte que la région ile-de-france
bénéficier un maximum des financements
européens
on sait que globalement aujourd'hui le
sentiment anti-européen prédomine sur le
vieux continent est ce que la région ile
de france elle dit merci à l'europe
aujourd'hui c'est un vrai lien
d'affection entre régions île de france
et union européenne
lien d'affection un tableau fort mais en
tout cas on y travaille
c'est justement pour ça qu'on ambitionne
vraiment de voir ce lien régulier et et
récurrent c'est pour ça que je suis au
moins une fois par mois à bruxelles sur
une journée complète justement pour voir
les différents interlocuteurs pour
qu'ils comprennent nos difficultés que
je comprenne les leurres aussi parce que
c'est pas ça va pas que dans un sens
mais après ce que je dis souvent à mes
interlocuteurs à la commission c'est de
dire aidez nous à vous aider
parce que le sentiment anti européen il
est surtout le sentiment anti commission
européenne anti technocratie européenne
et je leur dis si vous nous aidez être
efficace en simplifiant un peu les
règlements on sera d'autant plus
efficace sur le terrain et on sera
d'autant plus à travers notre action en
capacité de démontrer que l'europe
allait concrètes qu'elle est au près des
gens et qu'elle est utile et c'est
seulement parce à convaincre et à un
sentiment et une envie européenne alors
non sans un clin d'oeil je voulais
terminer là dessus sur l'actualité
européenne la région francilienne a
signé récemment il ya quelques mois un
accord de coopération dans parlait déjà
avec la catalogne concrètement
quel est l'objectif de cet accord en
quoi ça consiste un accord avec la
catalogne alors c'est un accord de
coopération essentiellement économiques
ou en fait nous avons identifié quelques
thématiques pas pas trente six mille
parce qu'on veut très très opérationnels
et je veux des duels et l'industrie du
jeu vidéo donc on a identifié un certain
nombre de thématiques en lien avec nos
pôles de compétitivité on leur a dit
voilà quelles sont les thématiques sur
lesquelles vous souhaiteriez travailler
avec avec l'espagne et en l'occurrence
avec la catalogue sont ressortis
plusieurs thématiques dont l'industrie
du jeu vidéo dont l'industrie du mieux b
du biomédical par exemple est alors
clairement ça se passe c'est que notre
pôle de compétitivité francilien se met
à travers nous en contact avec un pôle
de compétitivité catalan et y créer un
cluster francis catalan catalino
franciliens mutualiser les moyens
mutualisent les moyens qu'ils échangent
les process qui échangent les bonnes
pratiques et surtout plus important
encore qui vont monter des projets en
commun sont plus à l'échelle européenne
et qui seront beaucoup plus puissants et
qu'ils pourront de manière beaucoup plus
facile obtenir en plus des fonds des
fonds européens supplémentaires une
question aussi maintenant sur sur
l'actualité nationale puisque ml mâcon
se montre très offensif en ce moment sur
le sujet européen il ya le discours à
athènes le discours à la sorbonne il
veut relancer la construction du vieux
continent
il esquisse aussi une europe à plusieurs
vitesses qui permettrait d'aller
peut-être plus loin mais moins nombreux
est-ce que ça va dans le bon sens pour
vous qui ça va clairement dans le bon
sens d'avoir un président de la
république qui se saisissent à ce point
de manière positive
du sujet européen je ne peux que m'en
féliciter
on a vu le discours qu'il a prononcé
d'avoir été un discours ambitieux et
avec du souffle
mais plus important encore parce que ça
en politique on sait faire donner de
l'emphase
on s'est fait ce qui m'a plus
particulièrement intéressé c'est de voir
qu'il prenait un certain nombre de
thématiques très précise et qu'il y
mettait une méthode et ça c'est quelque
chose qui à mes yeux est déconcertant
précisément bas je pense par exemple
quand systématiquement il prenait des
exemples français en disant voilà on
engage ses réformes là en france on
souhaite qu'elles soient engagées en
europe jusqu'à présent avaient plutôt
tendance à faire l' inverse ont demandé
à l'europe de faire des efforts que nous
même en france nous n'étions pas
capables de faire nimani pas pour soi
c'est évident par exemple est donc cette
approche là me semble être une approche
certes ambitieuse mais crédible et je
pense qu'un certain nombre de
collectivités territoriales dont la
région ile-de-france ont à coeur d'être
précisément des acteurs de cette
nouvelle ambition européenne on en vient
maintenant à notre rubrique et chez nos
voisins ça se passe comment aujourd'hui
zoom sur un sujet qui va forcément
intéresser les franciliens les
transports en commun retards et
problèmes récurrents prix trop élevés
globalement les franciliens ne sont pas
tendres avec leurs transports en commun
mais alors est ce justifié combien
coûte-t-il ailleurs en europe sont ils
plus fiable plus fiables excusez moi les
plus confortables les réponses d'olivier
geynrikh ce responsable du centre europe
direct à saint germain en laye c'est là
où j'ai pu la plupart du temps les
capitales européennes maintiennent un
système de zones comme on avait avant en
ile-de-france avec sauna zone de zone 3
4 5 avec à chaque fois un système de
tarification qui s'adapte en fonction de
la zone que vous sur laquelle vous allez
si on prend quelques exemples par
exemple à londres où on a différentes
zone la moins chère si on prend
l'abonnement le moins cher on part de 94
livres ce qui donne à peu près 100 707
euros par mois jusqu'à à peu près 3 192
livres 50 pour l'abonnement le plus cher
ce qui donne à peu près 4 148 euros là
d'autres capitales qui ont aussi
qui ont imposé un tarif unique par
exemple c'est le cas notamment en suède
à stockholm où l'abonnement et 1,86
euros par mois la densité de transport
en commun dépend surtout de
l'aménagement de la capitale
si on prend la capitale d'allemagne
berlin
on a un assez bon réseau de transport en
commun notamment avec tout ce qui est là
où ban est là et ce ban donc
l'équivalent du métro et du rer sachant
qu'en plus il ya tout un tas de lignes
de bus qui circulent dans toute la ville
avec aussi l'équivalent on va dire chez
eux de notre transilien qui mène dans
les différentes villes aux alentours par
exemple potsdam
si on prend le cas de stockholm on a une
ville qui est beaucoup plus fluvial
parce qu'on a davantage de on a
davantage d'eau qui est présente donc on
n'a que trois lignes de métro
ça paraît peu par rapport à chez nous
mais qui est compensée par plus de rer
de leurs équivalents de rer et avec
aussi par exemple une grosse nouveauté
c'est des transports fluviaux
alors il est toujours très difficile
d'évaluer le rapport qualité prix parce
que tout dépend de ce qu'on fait rentrer
dans la qualité
par exemple si on prend les transports
en commun en espagne ils sont davantage
climatisés ce qui est un bon point par
rapport à la température du pays
si on prend les transports en commun à
berlin on a des stations qui sont
parfois assez vétustes notamment quand
elles sont dans le centre ville par
contre on a une excellente les personnes
handicapées n'ont absolument aucun
problème pour pouvoir rentrer dans les
transports en commun parce que justement
tout est mis à niveau afin de faciliter
leur utilisation des transports en
commun si on prend le cas de londres
on a quand même un réseau de
leur équivalent du métro il fait plus de
400 kilomètres donc c'est quand même
quelque chose d'assez important donc
afin d'améliorer la qualité est ce
qu'ils ont fait c'est qu'ils ont mis ils
ont fait un très gros effort sur
l'information en temps réel est donc à
chaque fois qu'il ya un souci on est
tout de suite prévenu que ce soit par
les haut-parleurs ou par les différentes
applications mobiles
stéphanie vendeuse une rapide réaction
sur le volet prix c'est ce qui est
intéressant souvent les gens on se rend
compte finalement que les parisiens sont
assez chanceux avec un pass navigo à 75
euros on a entendu les prix à londres
notamment ça fait deux ans maintenant
que le prix du pass navigo augmente il
était à 70 puis désormais 75 euros est
ce que ce sera encore le cas du coup
l'été prochain pour peut-être aussi
rattraper la moyenne européenne
je m'engagerai évidemment pas là dessus
d'abord puisque c'est par contre votre
sujet mais en revanche ce que je trouve
intéressant dans le reportage qui a été
fait c'est que c'est vraiment
l'application l'adage quand je me
regarde je me fais peur quand je me
compare je me rassure
et c'est moi c'est ce que j'apprécie
dans cette dimension européenne c'est
finalement d'avoir la curiosité pour
regarder comment ça se passe ailleurs et
en réalité on voit bien on peut trouver
70 75 80 euros on peut dire que c'est
cher oui c'est cher mais au regard du
service c'est toujours le débat si on
estime que le service le veau ou pas
mais ce que je trouve très important
c'est bien de bien faire comprendre aux
franciliens que des investissements un
service ça a un coût et que on ne fait
pas partie de ces gens qui est comme un
certain ancien président de la
république françois hollande pour pas le
nommer disait c'est pas cher parce que
c'est l'état qui paye
c'est une hérésie c'est à dire que ces
services-là ces investissements là il
faut les payer il ya un équilibre
économique à trouver on sait très bien
que forcément ça va devoir encore
augmenter le pass navigo mais de façon
finale
alors c'est parce qu'il n'y a pas
forcément de manière aussi automatique
que vous le dites simplement il faut se
rendre compte qu'il ya un coup d'
équilibre on savait très bien quand la
majorité précédente a voté le pass
navigo à tarif unique au tarif initial
que ça crée immédiatement un trou d'air
de 300 millions d'euros par an 300
millions d'euros par an et c'est le trou
qu'on a qu'on a prouvé qu'ils n'avaient
ils n'étaient pas comblés
donc le souhait de valérie pécresse
évidemment de continuer les années
si ce mot qui sont faits sur les
transports son plan d'urgence parce que
je vous rappelle que vous avez la
quasi-totalité des des des matériels
roulants qui sont qui sont rénovées ce
sens qu'ils sont 9 700 ram exactement et
puis le taf ne le passent le pass navigo
à tarif unique d'abord est maintenu
ensuite il a augmenté mais c'est pour
garantir justement cette qualité de
cette qualité de service merci stéphanie
von euw 9 d'avoir participé à ce 7,8
europe je rappelle que vous êtes vice
présidente du conseil régional d'île de
france en charge des affaires
européennes
merci aussi aux équipes techniques du
parlement européen de bruxelles pour cet
enregistrement vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission en replay sur notre site
internet est là commenté sur nos réseaux
sociaux tv 78 la semaine prochaine vous
retrouverez le 7-8 politique
[Musique]